we're going to win
i think we're going to win in virginia
the race is very close it's about who
shows up who turns out
and granted i did win by a large margin
i don't believe and i've not seen any
evidence that whether or not i am doing
well or poorly whether or not i've got
my agenda passed or not
is going to have any real impact on
winning or losing
president biden very confident about a
critical race seen as a referendum on
his failing administration polls close
less than two hours from now in the
fight to be virginia's next governor and
everything is on the line the race a
dead heat between republican glenn young
and democrat terry mcauliffe an
education is at the top of voters minds
an issue that mcauliffe says parents
should not have a say in
virginia has emerged as ground zero in
the fight over critical race theory and
who should be in control over what is
taught in the classroom macaula focuses
on teachers while young and wants to
empower parents in their final pitches
i want to build the best education i
want every child to have a world-class
education here in the commonwealth of
virginia as your governor i am going to
raise teacher pay above the national
average for the first time in the
history of our great commonwealth what
we won't do is teach our children to
view everything through a lens of race
where we divide them into buckets and
one group's an oppressor and one other
group's a victim and we pit them against
each other we steal their dreams we will
not be a commonwealth of dream stealers
so this seems like a big mistake judge
because i'm not a math genius but i
would assume there are more parents
than teachers in the commonwealth of
virginia and mcauliffe is just all in
with teachers look when you bring in
randy weingarten at the end of the
campaign and you have literally given up
on the parents you know that they're not
going to vote for you you know that
because the school board ends up lying
about whether or not someone was raped
and sexually assaulted in the bathroom
that all the parents are absolutely
against the democrats here so the issue
right now is whether or not this race
presents an opportunity for parents from
both sides of the aisle to come together
to unify in a way that we haven't seen
in this country in years
and this is a good thing about the race
i think that that that mcauliffe is over
the top he certainly has an advantage
from the early voters and youngkin has
to make sure that he gets a lot of
voters out today but the the bigger
issue i think is the fact that
mcauliffe has already made a decision
that he is with the unions he needs the
unions to help him that's why he's got
randy weingarten out there that's why
just promise he's going to give the
teachers more money i mean that's the
democrat way and at the end of the day
if if if younkin wins
it's about the fact that people now are
beyond party beyond politics it's about
america coming together and hopefully
it'll be a model for going forward
when joe biden popped off at the mouth
in glasgow guaranteeing victory
basically it seems to be
based on what do you think he knows
something or do you think he realized
that could totally blow up in his face i
think what he knows is he won the state
by 10 points he knows what judge the
judge just shared that there's a huge
voter turnout early on and you can
determine you know which party the
person declares when they vote so he's
guessing about that and apparently this
morning we've learned that there was
huge turnout in richmond charlottesville
and northern virginia
and the data shows those are normally
places where democrats fare well
the polling has been tight we had a big
poll uh the fox news release showing
that yunkan had gained some points there
at the end but
uh mcauliffe had held an early lead
before that so we're gonna have to wait
and see i'd say the third thing i was
surprised by by glen younkin's closing i
thought his clothes would have been more
we're going to take the commonwealth to
a new place we're going to create more
jobs create more prosperity here's a guy
that comes from business and to the way
he injected race at the end look it may
work for him but i was expecting
something more from him there at the end
terry ended on his note saying look
we're going to do we're going to make
education even better i'm going to pay
teachers more he had to try to divert
this conversation from some of the race
stuff and some of the parents stuff
but we've got a few hours left and we'll
see who wants i don't know if he has an
objective race i think the left injected
it and i just said his closing argument
is all i was saying okay okay degan
your thoughts are going to make a
prediction
i'm not going to make a prediction i was
down in virginia over the weekend oh by
the way yeah um a lot of signs a lot of
signs but she is so sad virginia
for you newbies it's south of the james
river so that's red territory but junkin
was was he he needs to get out the vote
in that part of the state that's
critical to the victory particularly in
southwest virginia
uh when
terry mccauley said i don't think
parents should be telling schools what
they should teach he meant it and
everything that he has done since then
you and now you know he meant it he
because he never learned from it he told
chuck todd two days ago that everyone
clapped when he said that
he then he then said virginia schools
need to get rid of white teachers too
many white teachers not bad lousy
incompetent teachers but white teachers
so you talk about injecting race into
this mcauliffe's on it uh he's last week
said teachers are the true heroes of the
coveted crisis well that's smooching the
rump of the unions not the moms who had
to quit their jobs and give up their
careers to sit at home and have their
children educated on zoom by said lousy
teachers then brandie weingarten showed
up at the mcauliffe rally the wicked
witch of unnecessary school closings
president obama came to the state and
then told dismissed belittled parents
and told them that they're imagining
what they're upset about in the schools
so this is all that just sends the clear
message to parents he has proved over
and over again that he does not care
about what the voters care about in that
state we'll see how many people woke up
to his
nonsense greg someone reported that
terry mcauliffe had left his wife in the
delivery room to go to a fundraiser did
you know that yes i did i kept it under
wraps
uh i was it's coming out of my book i
didn't want to break the news i'm sorry
you i wanted to tease it out sorry um
you know i was just uh in the green room
uh talking to harold and i told him you
know harold the story isn't about who
wins but how close the election is i
said that to him it's not the reverse
okay uh but this isn't this really
it's less a partisan election and it's a
parenting election it reminds me of the
quiet guy at the bar
who is being taunted and never gets up
until finally somebody knocks his drink
over and then he beats the crap out of
everybody that's basically what the
parents are they may not they may not
pull it off this time but i think the
democrats in the media got caught by
surprise
by the real things that matter to
american parents right you had for four
years in outraged media and an outraged
democratic party over trump's
personalities tweets the effects on
their emotional state mattered more than
dead bodies right meanwhile the real
issues kind of slipped right by them
coveted mandates crt crime so while the
the media and the democrats were focused
on microaggressions parents were
experiencing macro aggressions
you know through education politics is a
tug of war as you know between the
people who go too far and the people who
don't go far enough
right now it's the leftists that are
realizing how far they've gone and they
need somebody needs to pull them back in
and you see that how that they've turned
you know the police into defunding and
demoralizing the police and now you have
the crt stuff and you know being white
at birth is bad so they're the one that
have gone too far it's now time for the
republicans to pull that back in and
this might be a sign for that whether
they win or not i'm not making any
predictions that's not my job okay well
we will see if someone's beer gets
knocked over and how many people they
knock out tonight exactly it'll probably
be me downtown
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else